now the latest on U.S citizens getting
out of war-torn Sudan CBS News went
aboard a Saudi Arabian Navy ship sent to
the African nation to evacuate refugees
from the latest fighting thousands of
people are still just waiting to be
rescued Remy inocencio spoke to some of
the lucky ones they got out Remy good
morning
good morning we just got off that Saudi
military ship 10 hours West across the
Red Sea then 10 hours back Port Sudan
has been declared the country's new
administrative Capital which implies it
is the safest place to be in this
conflict
salvation from suffering and a passage
to peace for these exhausted evacuees
waiting for days at Port Sudan this is a
night of mixed emotions
how are you feeling right now
I feel scared
and excited at the same time refund is
13 years old now headed home to Georgia
and her father
I feel excited because we're going back
to America
to go into a safer place she and her
family waited for a boat for four days
desperate to be delivered from evils
committed by both Sudan's Army and its
strongest paramilitary force
the cool of Darkness from the midi Sun
embedded with the Saudi naval ship HMS
al-jubal our CBS News team arrived at
Port Sudan close to midnight
along the water's edge silhouettes of
waiting people stood out this boat
preparing to take its passengers from
the horrors of War
I saw a lot of bodies on the cities I
saw a lot of burn cars Mohammed Usman
worked for the U.S embassy it is very
hard to leave your
relative your sister your brothers your
uncle's but this is right because of the
war these are the fortunate few allowed
to leave Sudan but beyond this bubble
there are the less fortunate many
thousands if not more
sudden refugees with less responsive
governments or with passports that give
limited Mobility may be left to linger
to search for shelter to wait while
people with passports green cards and
work visas from North America and
Western Europe quickly get the green
light to go
who are you leaving behind
my whole family like my grandma my
grandfather my auntie my uncles these
type of people family members when you
said goodbye to them what did you say
I I said I love you to all of them as
the light support Sudan dimmed and
people looked back one last time on home
minutes later their passage appeared
above in the pale Moonlight and they
were lifted up to a more peaceful life
and just in a new seven-day ceasefire
has been declared between Sudan's
military and its para military forces
but the last three truces were broken
within hours in Port Sudan the Crowds
Are swelling people are still evacuating
and that means they will still be
leaving loved ones behind Gail
that's tough thank you very much Ramey
inocencio reporting